[THEME MUSIC]
ROBERT KUBIS: All right, what
am I going to talk today about?
So I'm going to talk about
optimizing applications
for scalability, so it's
like one of the more--
for me, more important points--
while keeping costs at bay.
So I'm going to talk a little
bit about some techniques
and some things that
sometimes are overlooked
to keep costs in control.
One warning in the
beginning, this
will be a somewhat
opinionated talk.
So I made choices on the
products that I show today.
There are many, many
more products out there.
This is really a
talk where I said,
OK, if I would build an
application that I want
to be able to scale and
still be in my budget,
these are the products
that I would choose.
So I will concentrate on that.
That is basically
a side note for you
that you know if there
are products missing.
What am I going
through today is I
give a little bit
of introduction,
basically terminology
that I use.
And then I go through the
full stack of my applications,
so presentation layer,
application, persistence,
logs, analytics, and
then talk a little bit
about related
sessions and resources
where you can find information.
A bit about myself, just
two words or maybe three.
I'm a Cloud Developer Advocate
for the Google Cloud platform.
So basically, we
are the interface
between developers and operators
building on top of our platform
and the developers
and operators that
built the platform
inside the company.
So we are your voice
into the company.
And we are the voice of
the engineers outside.
So please feel free to reach
out to me if you have things
where you think we can improve,
where you have challenges.
Also if you have good
stories and you just
want to tell us about it, how
amazing certain things are,
please, please reach out to us.
We want to relay that back
to the engineering team.
So you can find
me, for instance,
on Twitter under the
name @hostirosti.
All right.
Just a little bit
of a pulse check.
Who is here today?
Who is an engineer in the room?
All right, the majority.
That's my audience.
CXO, ITDM?
OK, so most engineers.
So what are the criterias
that I go through today
when I'm looking at some of the
products of the Google Cloud
platform?
So first of all, I'm going
to look at performance.
And performance,
what I understand
under that is basically
the response time,
like how quickly an
application responds.
Especially if you are
in the upper layers
of your application, you want
to have things being snappy.
So you want to have very
low latencies in terms
of round trip times and load
processing times, so to say.
It's especially important
in human interactions.
They don't want to wait for a
second or even half a second
until something loads up, right?
Second point, which is important
for me, is reliability.
So what happens if there's
something that fails?
Is there a failover?
Is there some
redundancy there that
can help me to have
my application still
up and running, even if
parts of my application fail?
The third part, and that
is part of the title,
is the scalability.
So what if-- what happens
if my application goes
viral and my user base grows?
Do I have to
re-architect completely?
Do I have to change system,
change products that I'm using?
Or can I just use them from
user zero to user one billion?
And last but not least,
also part of the title,
are the costs.
Now, costs are
not only the costs
that you get charged
on your credit card,
or if you're having offline
billing with us installed,
you have to pay per
bank wire, probably.
Not only these costs
are considered.
You should also consider
costs like migration costs,
costs of operation.
What is the human
labor that your company
has to put in to manage
certain systems, right?
So, yes, there are
systems out there
that are cheaper than others.
And it looks like,
why would I pay more?
But the labor cost adds up.
And so you should
consider that as well.
That's why you see in the cost
section not only the money
back.
You see also the
people involved there.
And I will make a couple of
statements along those lines
along this talk.
All right, so what
do I understand
on a full-stack application?
You saw it in the
agenda already.
So I, for myself, consider a
full-stack application being
a presentation layer--
so basically assets
that I serve--
then an application
layer, which basically
has my business logic and
processing, and a persistence
layer, which is basically my
storage, a database, things
like that.
On the side, I have on to one
side service APIs, so things
that you can call out into the
Google Cloud Platform, or even
other providers,
or even on premise.
And on the right
side, you have logging
and analytics,
which is integrated
in a lot of our products.
But you can also integrate
that into your applications
that you're writing.
All right, so let's start
with the presentation layer.
So my choices of
presentation layer--
I'm a big, big fan of Firebase.
Firebase makes it really, really
easy to start coding, getting
something up and running.
And part of the Firebase
platform and ecosystem
is the Firebase hosting.
So you see on the
right side there,
you have a portfolio of things
that you get out of the box
with Firebase, being
authentication, a database--
a NoSQL database, Firestore--
blob storage, cloud
storage, cloud functions
for processing, and hosting
for hosting static assets.
Now, it's very easy to
get started with Firebase.
But Firebase has also very
simple cost structures.
And so that might
mean at some point,
if you are at a certain
scale, that there
are more affordable
solutions out there for you
to save some costs.
So my second choice
here is, especially
if you're looking at scale,
cloud storage and cloud CDN.
So what am I looking at in
terms of the four criterias
that I mentioned before?
So if you look at
performance, we're good.
They are snappy.
CDNs, Firebase hosting
is also backed by a CDN.
So they are basically
at the edge points
which we have around the world
for Google Cloud platform.
So low latencies, great.
Reliability, static assets
are easy to replicate. right?
So you cache them everywhere
in the edge cases.
Even if one of your edges falls
down-- or multiple, even--
they can be fetched
from other edges.
So we have replication, so
we are also reliable on that.
Scalability, again, you
don't have strong consistency
constrains with static assets.
If you have higher ones, you
can set your cache timeout,
basically, low so that the cache
is refreshed more frequently.
But basically, since it's static
assets that we can replicate,
scalability is not
an issue, either.
And when it comes to
cost, I mentioned already
Firebase is kind of
like a static cost.
And Cloud CDN, Cloud
Storage are a little lower.
So what does it mean in detail?
What are the cost drivers
for my presentation layout?
So one of the big costs
drivers is egress.
So egress is basically
all the bytes
that we ship out of the Google
network to your clients,
to your customers.
These are the things where
you have to look into.
And they become--
again, in Firebase,
you have basically a flat rate.
For a small installation,
that is fine.
There will be a low difference
between the solution
that you use.
But if you go larger
scale, then egress actually
goes down depending on
the traffic that you have.
So increased traffic,
you get, basically,
down in what you pay per
gigabyte for your egress.
And that only gets--
you can only benefit
from that if you
use Google Cloud Storage.
Now, if you want to go
even lower in your prices
that you pay for
egress, then you
can use a CDN in front
of Cloud Storage, which
incurs a fill up cost.
So you have to basically shift
some data into the cache.
You pay that.
But then the egress cost
from the CDNs is quite a bit
lower than if you compare it,
for instance, with serving data
directly from Cloud Storage.
So if you are large scale,
please look into Cloud CDN.
And in front of
Google Cloud Storage,
this will be much
more affordable
than if you look at
standard Firebase
or just using Cloud Storage.
Now, the second one is
my application layer.
And for the application layer, I
chose three kind of categories.
So Cloud Functions
is available on GCP--
that's on Google
Cloud Platform--
as well as under the Firebase
umbrella and branding.
So you can use it directly from
your Firebase applications.
You can trigger them from HTTP.
You can direct them in
Firebase, for instance,
if you have any data changes
in your NoSQL database,
in the real-time database,
or in Firestore that
is available under Firebase.
So if you have any data
changes, you can automatically
trigger your Cloud Function.
Cloud Function under
GCP, you can also
trigger when, for instance,
on a Pub/Sub message.
So Pub/Sub is our
messaging system,
which is scalable beyond
belief, at least my belief.
You don't have to do any kind
of sizing or anything decisions.
You just pump data
in there and it
will arrive at the destination
where you want to have it.
And that is globally as well.
So that is also a
trigger that you
can use for Cloud Functions.
And another trigger
that you can use
is any kind of
storage operations.
So for instance, if you
use Cloud Storage, which
is our blob storage, if you
store a file or modify a file,
you can also tweak
a Cloud Function
to do any kind of
post-processing if you want to.
The second choice for
my application layer
is App Engine.
So App Engine has a couple of
really nifty and nice features.
It's scaling down to
zero, for instance.
It's flexibly scaling.
So there are some
comparisons that you
can draw between Cloud
Functions and App Engine.
But there are also
some differences.
And then the third choice is
basically Kubernetes engine,
which is a running container.
So it is our managed Kubernetes.
Kubernetes is a
container orchestrator
where you can run
your containers
and Kubernetes takes care of
restarting them if they fail.
It's taking care
of node management,
resource management,
things like that.
You can install a service
mesh in Kubernetes
to have discoverability,
have security in there,
things like that.
So there are a lot of things
that you do manage yourself
in Kubernetes which are managed
for you in, for instance,
App Engine and Cloud Function.
So let's have a look
at our four criterias.
I know they all look green.
I have a couple that are not
green, just to mention that.
But basically, if you
look at Cloud Functions,
like performance, reliability,
so Cloud Functions,
unless it's the very first
call, which takes a little bit
of a warm-up--
but if you have follow up calls,
then they are really snappy.
They're in low tens of
milliseconds, depending,
of course, on your processing,
how much processing
you do in your Cloud Function.
But if you, for instance,
just return a "hello, world,"
you can get into the tens of
milliseconds in response time.
In terms of reliability,
Cloud Functions
is running on our
infrastructure.
It's also you
basically-- you just
can scale very
easily in containers.
And if one falls down, we
can just reroute the traffic
to another one that is live.
And they are in a region,
so they can be brought up
in different zones.
So even if a zone
becomes unavailable,
your Cloud Function
is still available.
In terms of scalability, I
mentioned, as I say there,
order of seconds.
So if you have to warm up new
instances of your container,
which runs the
Cloud Function, it
is usually at the order
of very low second range.
Now, for App Engine, it's
a very similar story.
So App Engine has
certain constraints
in terms of processing.
If you have a front
end processing job,
it's constrained to 60 seconds.
After 60 seconds, we
basically time it out.
In Cloud Functions, you have
nine minutes to process.
After nine minutes, we basically
stop the function processing.
So these are boundaries
that you have
to consider if you do certain
kinds of business logic.
For App Engine, we have
our own processes which
are allowed to run much longer.
I don't have the exact
number right now,
but they're allowed to
run much longer if you
need to do some asynchronous
background processing.
Now, for Kubernetes, if
you're inside the Cloud store,
you still have
resources available.
Then you can scale at the
order of milliseconds.
So bringing up a
port is pretty fast,
unless you do a lot of warm-up
initialization in your port.
But I'm a big fan, for
instance, of writing Golang apps
nowadays.
And I statically
link these binaries
and put them in
my container that
makes the containers very
small, so even if they have
to be fetched from a registry.
And then they are started
up in milliseconds,
really, really, really quick.
Now, if you run out of sources
in your Kubernetes engine
cluster, you need to
scale the cluster.
And that is basically adding
Compute Engine instances.
And that is at the
order of minutes.
So it takes about 30 seconds
to bring up a Compute Engine
instance.
And then it takes about
another 30 seconds
to basically set up the
whole Kubernetes stack which
we need to manage that node.
Now, the advantage
of Kubernetes is also
you don't have any kind of
runtime restrictions there.
So you basically
run your container.
It can run whatever
you want in there.
It basically runs
on the Linux kernel.
You can run your
container on there
and you don't have restrictions,
like how long it can run
and it gets stopped,
or things like that.
Now what are cost drivers
for Google Cloud Function, so
a GCF, Google Cloud Function?
GAE is Google App Engine.
GKE is Google Kubernetes Engine.
What are the cost drivers here?
So for functions, you have,
basically, an instance type
that you can choose.
It's memory and
processing power-based,
so CPU hertz-based.
You see there, it's from 128
megabytes to two gigabyte.
Based on the size
that you choose,
you have a certain cost per
second for that instance.
And then it's basically
also a call count.
Depending on how
many calls you have,
we basically time how long
your function is running,
and then we calculate
the cost there.
All of those, what's coming
in is the egress as well.
Now, the advantage of
the egress for these ones
is that for Cloud
Functions it's a baseline.
So you basically pay
the same no matter
if you call it once a day or
100,000 times or a million
times a day.
For App Engine, it's the same.
Now, for Kubernetes
Engine, we price the egress
based on our standard
networking prices.
And the networking
prices is based
in the sense of that the
more traffic you have,
the lower the price
goes for egress.
So consider that if you
have a big application which
gets viral, your application
will become cheaper over time
the more traffic you get if you
run it on Kubernetes versus App
Engine or Google Cloud Function.
Now, one note to that,
if you run Kubernetes,
even if you run
Kubernetes Engine,
the managing of your
applications on Kubernetes
will incur labor costs.
So you have to consider that.
Now, yes, you have that
also with App Engine.
You also have that
with Functions.
But there are a little
bit of differences
in the magnitude, how much
management, labor cost
management is there.
Now, for the sizes,
basically, if you
have jobs which require a lot
of memory or a lot of CPU power,
you are out of luck, pretty
much, in GCF or in GAE.
They are capped
at-- for Google App
Engine at one gigabyte
memory, for GCF at two,
and at 2.4 gigahertz
of processing power.
Now, for Kubernetes
Engine, you basically
can take big machines,
take your 64 core machine
with two terabytes
of main memory.
And if your port needs a
terabyte of main memory,
so be it.
You can do it.
So consider that, as well.
If you have some really
heavyweight processing,
you might want to go more
to a GKE-based system
than something else.
All right, number
three, and that
is more-- that is basically
my big passion as a Google
Developer Advocate for
the Cloud platform,
is the persistence layer.
So now we have a couple
of different types
of persistence products there.
The first one that you
see here is Cloud Storage.
So Cloud Storage is
basically a blob store.
So if you have any kinds of
objects that you want to store,
any kinds of assets,
then Cloud Storage
is what you want to use.
Cloud Firestore is our
NoSQL document, so to say,
document database where you
can store data without having
to pre-define a schema.
And that's very
flexible in terms of it
can grow in terms of processing
as well as data very flexibly.
Cloud SQL, you have basically
a managed MySQL or Postgres.
And Cloud Spanner is our
relational database system
which is horizontally scalable.
Now, if we look at Cloud
Storage and Firestore
in terms of for reliability,
scalability, performance,
they are pretty snappy.
They're very quick.
The really nice feature
of Cloud Storage
is that the listing
is strong, consistent.
So if you add a file
to Cloud Storage
and you are at the
other end of the world
and you ask if that
file exists, it
will give you a strong,
consistent view.
If you look from two
places in the world--
let's say it this way.
If you look from two places
in the world at roughly
the same time, you will get
the same view of the data
you have in Cloud Storage.
That is not true for
a lot of other systems
that are out there in the world.
In terms of scalability, they're
very scalable, these systems.
You don't have to look
at sizing or anything.
You basically start
from zero and you grow.
It grows with your application.
You don't have to
worry about-- you
don't have to give us any sizing
information or any of this.
Now, if your app gets
really, really viral--
I don't want to
name the company.
But there are certain companies
that build their whole business
on App Engine and
Datastore, which is
the predecessor of Firestore.
Now, if you get at that billion
dollar valuation kind of scale,
please still talk to us.
We want to make sure that your
business runs reliable and gets
the performance that you need.
So we give you some
dedicated resources for that.
Now, if you look in the
relational database area,
we have Cloud SQL
and Cloud Spanner.
Now, that's where my
first non-green check
marks are coming, or crosses.
If you look at Cloud SQL,
in terms of reliability,
now Cloud SQL is, out
of the box, basically,
a single host system.
So if this system falls,
down you become unavailable.
So you don't have, necessarily,
out-of-the-box replication.
Now, what you can
do with Cloud SQL
and the Google Cloud
platform is you
can actually set up
a failover instance.
And you can set up read replicas
to get a little bit more
scalability out of your system.
But even if we have to failover
to your failover database,
it will incur little downtime.
It will take some time
to basically catch up
with the logs and
stuff like that.
Now, if you look at scalability
for Cloud SQL, for instance,
you can upsize your
Cloud SQL instance.
So you can scale it vertically.
You can jump between
different sizes of instance
sizes between Cloud SQL.
But they are, at some
point, capped, right?
You have a maximum instance
size that we can support.
And if you outgrow
that, you're of luck,
pretty much, unless you are
building your application
on top that can manage to
distribute your application
workload across multiple Cloud
SQL instances, for instance.
But even if you
upgrade your instance,
then you are at the order of
at least minutes, if not hours,
to basically do that upgrade.
And your customers
can't access or do
things with your application
during that time.
Now, if we look
at Cloud Spanner,
this was designed
with the idea in mind
to actually eliminate
these boundaries,
eliminate the
boundaries of scaling,
and eliminating the boundaries
of having maintenance,
even if it's planned
maintenance outages.
Now, Cloud Spanner is still,
even though it gives you
the quality, a
relational database
with strong consistency.
So we have strong consistency
across tables, regions,
and even globally
that you get there.
And you can do
no-downtime updates.
So you can basically add
nodes or remove nodes
from Cloud Spanner,
depending on your workloads.
And you can also
update your schema,
which is running
inside a transaction
as well, even while you're
serving live traffic.
So now what are the cost drivers
for Cloud Storage, Firestore,
SQL, and Spanner?
So for Cloud Storage,
it's basically
the storage and egress.
For Firestore, you are charged
based on the operations, so
storage and, again, egress.
You have heard that by
now a couple of times.
Cloud SQL, based on the
instance type that you choose
and if you have a failover
instance and read replicas,
that basically adds
to the cost as well.
So if you want to have high
availability and disaster
recovery, that's basically
what you pay for.
And Cloud Spanner, we charge
you based on the configuration
that you use.
So configuration is
basically, do you
want to have a
regional instance?
Do you want to have a
multi-region continental
instance?
Or do you want to have a
multi-region global instance?
Based on that, we
charge different amounts
of money per node that
you provision with us.
And then, yeah, basically the
node count that you choose
is what drives the cost.
And again, also, we have egress
cost there that you incur.
Now, how can you
optimize on these levels?
So one optimization that
is many times overlooked
in Cloud Storage is the
storage classes that you have.
So the storage classes is we
have a multi-region storage,
we have a regional storage
class, we have nearline,
and we have coldline.
And especially if you go
to nearline and coldline,
the storage cost at
rest goes down a lot.
Now, there are certain
things we can, of course--
storage costs go down.
But we cannot just lower the
prices without giving some
constraints on these.
So if you go to
nearline, we recommend,
if you have data
that is not accessed
more than once a
month, then its worth
to move your data to nearline.
If you access it more
than once a month, then
you'll actually incur
more costs because we
give a little bit of penalty
for retrieval of data
if you use nearline.
Now, coldline is
basically for something
where you want to have
archival or backups
that you don't hope
and expect to use.
So coldline is-- or
something for legal reasons
that you have to
store for a long time.
Coldline is if you access
data less than once a year.
So if you access data once
a year or twice a year,
coldline is already
more expensive
than a regional instance.
Now, the really cool thing
in Google Cloud platform
for Google Cloud Storage is that
these storage classes are not--
you can define buckets.
So you can define buckets
where your objects go in,
and then all of your data
that goes into that bucket
gets that storage class.
But that's not the only
way to have storage classes
for your objects.
You can actually use one bucket
and have different storage
classes for the
object in a bucket.
And so there's something
called object lifecycle.
And for the object
lifecycle, you
have the option, for instance,
say, OK, if that object is not
accessed for,
let's say, 30 days,
please move it to nearline.
If it hasn't been
accessed for 365 days,
please move it to coldline.
And you can define
these policies,
and this is done
automatically for you.
So you don't have to--
you define these policies once.
And then you say,
I'm off the hook.
Over time, the data
that I'm storing,
it's going to be getting
cheaper for me, right?
So you don't have to keep
that at top of the mind.
OK, I have to run a run job that
basically moves these objects.
Now, another thing that you can
do that I did in a demo at I/O
is, for instance, if you have
certain blobs that come in,
like videos, or images,
or something like that,
that you do a processing of-- so
you do, for instance, generate
thumbnails, or you do
re-decoding of your videos
or things like that, and you
want to keep the raw image
or raw video footage around,
but you know you're not actually
serving that very often,
you can, right after you
process your data,
change the storage
class of that raw object.
And you basically say, OK, I'm
processing the data right now.
Once the last
process is finished,
I move it to coldline.
And you're done, right?
So you can do that with client
libraries and our APIs as well.
So you can do that
programmatically.
Now, for Firestore, what I
recommend to basically keep
costs under control,
look at using limits,
like how much data you get
returned from your queries.
Look at cursors and offset.
So basically, you
can use a cursor
if you do paging that
you only really get
the data into your application
and presentation layer
that you're actually serving to
your customer or to your user.
Don't get all the data
and do some processing.
If you do that every time,
you incur basically a lot
of costs on these operations.
So we have costs
attached to reads,
writes, and delete
operations on Firestore.
And another recommendation
is to do analytics outside.
So consider, if you store data
and you use it operationally
in Firestore for
your application,
if you do want to do
analytics over your data,
consider moving that data out,
for instance, into BigQuery.
For Cloud SQL, things
to basically look out
for keeping costs under
control, use the right size,
the right instant size.
Of course, do a
projection where you
can grow so that you don't
have to change the instance
size every month, and how
your traffic pattern is.
But the instance size is
basically your granularity
that you can choose to
have costs under control.
And then you have things like
failover and read replicas.
So don't just right away
create a read replica
if you don't need it.
So there are certain
capabilities of your Cloud SQL
instance out of the box
where you don't necessarily
need the read replica.
So read replica comes in
if you hit, basically,
the boundaries of your
Cloud SQL instance in terms
of write and read throughput.
If you want to get a little bit
higher in the write throughput,
you can consider a
read replica, which
will take away a little bit
of the work from your master,
or leader node.
And then you can, with that,
get a little bit more headroom
in the write throughput
on your instance.
Now, for Cloud
Spanner, we recommend
to scale depending on your
traffic, on your workload,
basically.
So do some tests,
watch how your traffic
is for your application.
And you are charged
on a granularity
of an hour on Cloud Spanner.
So don't do scaling
every 10 minutes.
So basically, do a
little bit, like--
space the scaling
a little bit out.
So you pay for a node,
anyway, for an hour.
So consider that if
you program any kind
of scaling for your
Cloud Spanner instance.
All right, number four
is logs and analytics.
And before I'm going to
go in logs and analytics,
I want to show really quick--
I mentioned Cloud Firestore.
And I want to show a
little demo, at least,
for Cloud Firestore.
So I'm going to switch
to my laptop here.
And some of you might
have seen it already.
We have it as a showcase demo.
So basically, what I wanted to
show with Cloud Firestore is
it's very easy to keep
multiple applications
on different platform--
no, an application
on different platforms
and devices in sync,
so we allow something
that you can watch
for data changes in Firestore.
This is a feature that we had
for the real-time database
under Firebase.
And so what you see here
is basically the console
for Firestore under Firebase.
And you see here we
have a database one.
We have some data.
We have some rules, basically
who can access the data.
You can define indexes or
remove indexes if you want to.
And you can see the usage,
basically, of how much data
we're processing.
Now, in this demo,
what I wanted to show
is the scalability that is
possible with Firestore.
So the demo is I have devices
which are watching a document.
So I'm going to show you,
really quick, this document.
You have basically
here a document
that can change a color.
Every time I change a color,
10,000 imitated devices
are catching that data change.
They get basically notified
about the changing color.
You just saw it changing.
They get notified about
the changing color.
And once they get that, they
write that back, actually,
to Firestore.
So this color that you see
here is in my import document.
So I have four import documents.
I split up, basically,
the Firestore logo
into four pieces.
And then you see here a
color and a timestamp.
And every time we see a
change, these devices report
that back to the database.
Now, how do I want
to visualize that?
The way that I'm
visualizing this is,
actually, you have here on the
left side the Firestore logo.
And each pixel,
each color pixel,
is represented by one device.
Now, if I change the
color you see here,
the color change gets basically
propagated to these 10,000
devices per section.
In total, we have
40,000 devices.
Every time a color changes,
they get basically propagated,
and then I display
that in my display app.
And I didn't have to do anything
for that in terms of looking,
how do I notify my devices
or things like that?
I just used the
client libraries,
and all this is done
automatically for you.
The next thing that I wanted
to talk about a little bit
is logs and analytics.
So we have a couple of products
there that help you to analyze
your usage patterns, your
data that you are collecting,
that you want to analyze
to, for instance,
machine learning to get
insights into your business,
to find out what works
reliably and what doesn't.
So the products of my
choice here in that area
are BigQuery, which is
basically an OLAP relational
database for massive
scale data analytics.
And I'll show a little
demo in a second.
The second one is
Cloud DataFlow.
Cloud DataFlow is a data
processing infrastructure
and, basically,
platform where we
have a library or, basically,
a programming model
that we open sourced under the
Apache Beam umbrella, which
allows you to write data
processing pipelines that work
always in streaming mode
and in benching mode, which
is very powerful.
And then if you have
already any kind
of existing data
analytic pipelines,
be it in Apache Hadoop
or in Apache Spark,
you can run these, basically,
and migrate them, basically,
in a lift and shift manner and
run them on Cloud Dataproc.
So now, if we look
at all these metrics,
again, in terms of scalability,
reliability, and performance--
performance, well, they are
not end user infrastructure
products that you use.
You don't use these products
to serve something directly
to your users.
So don't use BigQuery
directly connected
into your application.
If you use BigQuery,
please cache--
do some caching on top of
it, otherwise your users
have to wait a
little bit of time.
So query run times in BigQuery
are usually at least a second,
right?
This is not a real-time,
fast answer query machine.
And that's just, by the nature,
how BigQuery is designed.
Now, for Cloud DataFlow,
it's pretty similar.
For data going through DataFlow,
it incurs some latencies.
So you don't want to
rely on that, either.
Basically, these
are async systems
to use in the async matter.
And then Cloud Dataproc, as
mentioned, is a system for you
that you can use Apache
Hadoop or Apache Spark on it.
And they're, in terms of
scalability and performance,
all built on Google Cloud
Platform on our infrastructure.
And we make sure that
these are up and running.
Especially, if you
look at BigQuery,
they are running on
so many machines.
Even if a machine falls down,
another one picks up the work.
And it's similar
for Cloud DataFlow.
Now, what are the cost
drivers for these systems?
If you look at BigQuery,
it's basically scanned data,
or what your query
touches in terms of data.
Storage, which is very
reasonably priced,
it's pretty much priced on
nearline and coldline prices
for Cloud Storage.
So you can actually keep
your data in BigQuery,
and you don't have to move
it out into Cloud Storage
or move it back in.
BigQuery has also
federation mode.
So you can actually
use data that
is directly stored in Cloud
Storage and query that data.
Now, we don't have the data
storage optimizations there.
So queries will be
a little bit slower.
But you can, if you
want to, directly
query data that is
laying in Cloud Storage.
Now, for DataFlow, you
pay for per virtual CPU.
So you pay a GCE instance.
And then the virtual CPU,
you pay how much memory
you want to probation for that.
You pay for the
storage that you use
and the data that you
process, basically.
We have some cool
services on the DataFlow.
So we have a shuffle
service, which
is outside of your
instances, which
uses a novel way of
shuffling your data,
which can free up a lot
of the size requirements
on your instance.
So if you use our
shuffle service,
you need smaller instances
to process your data.
So you can save on
that and then you
pay us a little bit for the
shuffling service, which
is also more
performant and faster.
On Cloud Dataproc,
basically GCE instances
that you use-- so you can
use the instances that we
have available.
You can also customize your
instances for your pipelines
that you want to use.
And you pay a premium,
a Dataproc premium,
on top of this per
CPU, I believe.
And what we charge is the
minimum of one minute,
but we charge it per second.
And then the choice
is, basically,
what you have for saving costs,
if you look right away on Cloud
Dataproc, is, one, you
can use preemptible VMs.
So if your jobs allow you,
basically, that machines
become unavailable
if you re-claim them
and your job can pick up
the work from a machine
that we reclaim, then you
can use preemptible VMs.
And preemptible VMs are
considerably cheaper
than GCE instances that
you basically can keep.
So consider that to optimizing
your costs on the analytics
side.
For Cloud DataFlow, you
have the possibility
to provision Standard
Persistant Disk, or SSD.
So SSD is also
considerably more higher
priced than standard PDs.
So that's also
something to consider
based on your requirements
off how fast your analytics
pipeline have to run.
So that's something that
you should test, basically,
for your workloads,
what is cheaper.
If you run with SSD,
then maybe your pipelines
are shorter in the
time that they need.
And you can pay less
for the instance costs
but a little bit more
for the persistent disk.
So that's something that you
should check on your workloads.
And for Big Query, what we
recommend for optimization
is run your queries on
a small dataset first.
Make sure that your queries are
optimized on a small data set.
Don't run them on
your entire data set.
You will incur a lot
of costs every time.
So run it on a small data set.
Optimize them that they read
as few of data as possible.
And then you can run them
across your entire data
set that you want to do.
And then another
option is you have
the choice between on-demand and
flat rate billing for BigQuery.
So consider-- if you are running
a lot of BigQuery queries
or jobs, then consider,
too, our flat rate
pricing, which can help you
as well to save some cost.
All right, let me show you
a quick demo for BigQuery.
I just want to show you the
sheer amazing amount of data
that you can crunch in
a little bit of time.
So here what I'm
going to do is I
want to look at all the
Wikipedia articles that
have "happiness" in their title
from 1st of July until today.
So I'm going to run this job.
And that goes against the
data set that we basically
have in terms of page
views on Wikipedia,
which is updated constantly.
And you see here we
have a nine-second query
for 130 gigabytes of data.
Wow, that's cool.
Nine seconds.
130 gigabyte is maybe
not that impressive.
Let's see how that is if we look
over the entire year so far.
So its from 1st of
January until today.
Again, you see
there in this query
that I'm actually doing a regex.
Now, I'm caching.
I don't want to cache.
Let me uncache.
And let me run this again.
Hide the options.
So basically, I'm
looking, again,
for the same happiness
in the article.
And I'm running that
for the entire data
set I have for this year.
And I'm doing on each
of the titles a regex.
A regex, it's not
so straightforward.
You actually have to
look into the data.
And you can't use an index or
things like that, necessarily.
So what you see here, I
processed one terabyte of data
in 20 seconds.
Now, we have,
actually, demos where
we process petabytes of
data in under a minute
or around a minute.
So BigQuery is really,
really powerful
in processing vast
amounts of data.
And you pay, basically, for
the data that is processed.
All right, in terms of
resources and related sessions,
where can you find
out about pricing?
So we have a pricing
calculator on our web page.
It's cloud.google.com
/products/calculator,
where you can choose between
the different products and size
them.
And then you get a price,
basically, an estimated price,
what you're going to pay.
Another thing that
I want to mention
is that we have a free tier.
We have always free
tier, basically,
for products until
otherwise stated.
But for now, as always,
it's basically every month
that you get a free tier.
And a lot of the products
that I mentioned today
actually have a free tier.
So you can try them out.
And even if you
write a small app,
you could end up paying nothing
and running that application.
So consider that if you
want to check out GCP.
And then in terms of
sessions to look into,
I have a couple that
I recommend to look
if you care about costs and
keeping costs under control.
So first is the
managing costs in GCP.
It's talking about
the structures
that you have to
manage costs in GCP.
Another one is
about controlling.
So that one was yesterday.
It's recorded.
It's on YouTube, so you can
check it out on YouTube.
Another one is
controlling cloud costs
with GCP and finance governing.
That one, again,
was also yesterday.
It was also recorded.
I would look into.
Then we have one on
monitoring and forecasting,
as well as how to look
into your billing data
with BigQuery and DataStudio.
So the one BigQuery
and DataStudio
is happening right now.
So again, you need to use
YouTube to check that out.
And then we have one tomorrow
on monitoring and forecasting
on GCP.
[MUSIC PLAYING]